dolly parton is ready to tell her iconic
life story in a biopic and she would
like several different actresses to
portray her at various stages in her
life according to cnn dolly is eyeing
down tony winner kristin chenoweth
saying
she's just absolutely fantastic i
thought she'd be an ideal person to do
that yes and uh speaking on the mr
nashville talks podcast dolly also
weighed in on who could play her long
time musical partner porter wagner
here's what she had to say about that
you knew who would make a great porter
though in all seriousness i haven't
approached him about this but um
oh goodness what's the guy that does ace
uh
ventura oh
jim
jim carrey jim carrey yeah jim carrey
yeah cause he's uh i couldn't i know i'm
i'm old i forgot i was thinking i was
trying to think of his name but it
flashed on me one day i thought you know
because he's a great actor he's a crazy
comedian but porter had a great crazy
fun side to him too but he's got that
look and he's got the over exaggerated
so uh i thought well he might be a good
person to play porter someday i've been
as you know talking about doing my
broadway musical and we were really
really way out ahead and the cove hit
with that and then that that changed my
mind about a whole lot of things i do
intend someday to be on broadway but i'm
thinking now that i might do my life
story as a feature and maybe maybe
possibly even a musical
feature
and so i'm wearing talks about that
christian channel great remember when i
was saying that jlo was the greatest
person ever created you lied i don't
know i'm looking starting to read now
you're looking at those pyramids i don't
know i'm looking at dolly
she's got to be close i will say gotta
be cool
we've done a lot more uh dolly
appreciation stories here yes than we
have done jlo appreciation stories so i
don't know i don't know sitting in front
for anybody who's a dolly fan
sitting in front of dolly parton as that
guy was as anybody else who's ever had
the privilege of sitting in front of
dolly parton um
thousands of people you've interviewed
for the show thousands of people i've
interviewed for the show sitting in
front of dolly parton is different
and i can't explain what it is it's just
different it's almost like being in the
presence of magic you know what if that
makes sense it is it actually is like
you know they say oh this person has a
glow
it's like a glow it's like a warm
feeling you get
my experience the first time an
interviewer was like i'm going to be
interviewing diet partner this is i
can't i cannot believe this yeah and i
went and i was like i was nervous and i
had my questions and i thought like
what's the protocol this and that and
immediately she was like
we're pals like that's the feeling that
she gave off we're pals you're safe here
what like what's going on how are you
yeah how how am i doing i'm here to talk
to you she wanted to get my story we're
chatting there's invitations going
around back and forth and it felt like
it felt like we had known each other
forever and it was all just her
being like i know how to do this i'm
comfortable i'm gonna make you
comfortable and we're gonna have a great
conversation yeah no it is it's really
great and you know did you see what you
did to dollywood did you see that story
a couple weeks ago so i guess at
dollywood if you work at dollywood
dollywood will also pay for your
post-secondary education amazing even
for part-time workers yeah isn't that
crazy amazing right she's magic she's
getting higher on that pyramid roz she
is i know she's getting i know i know i
know i know is jlo paying college
tuition first please well we'll break
that story when it happens i don't know
she is man dolly may be at the top i may
have she might be there at the top maybe
i don't know